avec donné c'est votre avis
la france soutient le pouvoir algérien
depuis au moins 50 ans maintenant ou au
contraire
était le plus proche à présent des
d'une certaine élite algérienne et de
cette jeunesse qui manifeste qu'à
manifester régulièrement contre ce
pouvoir
non nous soutenons surtout le régime
algérien depuis longtemps alors
des modalités différentes selon les
périodes et notamment de manière assez
discrète pendant les années noires avec
deux objectifs c'était d'éviter
effectivement la montée de cet islamisme
en algérie ce qui n'a pas pu être
malheureusement éviter les surtout
qu'elle déborde sur notre territoire et
puis les questions d'immigration mais
moi je voudrais bien une anecdote très
amusante je me trouvais pour les 50 ans
d'indépendance de l'algérie à alger et
je discutais avec rza bras qui était le
conseiller antiterroriste de bouteflika
à l'époque et je lui demandais pourquoi
est-ce que l'indépendance n'était pas
aussi fêté j'étais surpris de ne pas
voir plus de manifestations et il m'a
répondu tu sais on en a pas fini avec
notre être alors je dis mes deux petites
il parlait ce que sont air qui me dit
non au traître au sein du fln tu sais
très bien quand on critique la france
c'est d'abord pour des questions de
politique intérieure
[Musique]